[Music]
I guess I'm lucky that my chosen
profession is astrophysics because
unlike so many other fields of study
especially academic fields of study in
my field we have a essentially
completely transparent lexicon so I
don't have to translate anything hardly
anything but I show you a photograph of
the Sun and you see spots on the Sun and
say what do you call those and I say we
call them sunspots I'll show you a
picture of Jupiter oh there's that red
spot and the southern hemisphere of
Jupiter what do you call that we call
that Jupiter's red spot there's this
place where you fall in and you don't
come out and like doesn't escape what do
you guys call that black hole so I don't
see myself translating anything I don't
have to I celebrate discovery using all
the language that is fundamental to my
field and what it means is to the person
listening that they don't have to slog
through navigate through vocabulary to
gain access to the interesting idea
that's sitting on the other side of it
so let's take biology for example and
the tribe they discovered
deoxyribonucleic acid now if you don't
know biology these are just syllables
coming out of your mouth well what is it
well it encodes the identity of life and
it's in the shape of a double helix so
fortunately double helix that that's a
word and there's nothing else really
that's a double helix so that's kind of
a translated term for deoxyribonucleic
acid but notice you spend all this time
just getting through the word before you
get to an understanding or conversation
about what it does and how it does it
and why so I'm lucky that my field does
not have this lexicon challenge for the
educator but what I also do is I've come
to recognize the obvious that everyone
exists with a certain pop culture
scaffold that they carry with them
that's the definition of pop culture so
it's not everyone but it's most people
there's a common base of knowledge that
we can all reference we all know what
football is in America if we know it
what we mean when we say football
what is baseball who is Beyonce who is
Donald Trump who is Hillary Clinton what
is the capital building you know there's
things we just know as part of pop
culture once I recognize that you are
walking around with a pop culture
scaffold
I can then clad that scaffold if I think
about how to do it
I can clad that scaffold with real and
genuine science and you will care about
it because I'm attaching it to something
that I know in advance you already do
care about or already do know about just
as a quick example I was channel surfing
came across a a football game that had
just ended in a tie they went into
overtime at 15 minutes to kill before my
movie came on I said that I sit there
and watch this overtime period and I'm
watching it and there's the requisite
exchange of possession before you go
into sudden death overtime so they get
it to within 50 yards of the goalpost
and so they decide to kick a field goal
for the win and so I'm watching this all
this it's exciting right so then the
ball gets hiked to kick the ball tumbles
and it heads towards the left upright
careens off the left post and in for the
win and I said wait a minute who we have
a round ball on a cylindrical thing so
fractions of an inch matter
which way this will bounce off of a post
so I said let me check this out so I
check the orientation of the stadium the
latitude of the city and I did a
calculation and then I tweeted and I
said the winning field goal by the
Cincinnati Bengals in overtime was
likely enabled by a third of an inch
drift to the right enabled by Earth's
rotation and because all my guys blow by
mile and the local news got it everybody
got it and but just see what just
happened there so let's just see what
happened there I did not have to explain
to you in advance what football is what
a 50-yard field goal is what an what the
goalpost is I didn't have to explain any
of that you came to the table with that
knowledge and then I attached a relevant
phenomenon in physics to it and now
these are forever connected within you
of course you want to know that the
rotation of the earth helped that fuel
go kick because a kick going due north
or due south will be deflected to the
right in the northern hemisphere and
it's exactly what happened to that kick
and I use that as an excuse to send out
a second tweet saying by the way we call
this the Coriolis force and that's what
creates the circulation of all storms
hurricanes tornadoes what do they call
them in the Pacific cyclones and so I
got to slip in a little bit of physics
earth physics almost for free without
sitting you down and starting a lesson
plan on the subject that
simply works now what I need is I need a
utility belt that I carry with them in
so it's football I should know enough
about football to even go there I need
to know enough about Game of Thrones to
comment on what's going on in a
scientific way that you might find
interesting
I need to know enough about these
Olympic sports as they are being
conducted so if I comment on it you will
care because you care about the halfpipe
you care about the slalom skiing or you
care about the sprinters you I'm going
to attach it to it so call it tactical I
don't know but I have found that people
like it and they come back for more and
I'm delighted to supply the body of
science that I know in the package that
you will receive without thinking like
you're being lectured to without
thinking of learning something new today
as a chore and I'm delighted to be in a
position to do that but by the way it
takes extra time out of my day to stay
connected with the pop culture frontier
we don't generally get rewarded for
knowing the hottest TV shows in the
physics lab the physics lab is like what
you watch TV and you should have been in
the lab why do you know about Beyonce
when you should have been writing a
paper so there's there's tension there
between how one would invest their time
and energy but I guess we can think of
it as just making science relevant and I
think any good teacher already knows
this oh one last thing if I can't find a
way to connect the science to your pop
culture scaffold I might just skip over
it because why sort of weigh down the
conversation with because I'm not here
to deliver curriculum I'm here to just
talk about really cool science now there
are there is science it is so cool
that I don't have to attach it to your
pop culture scaffold
I it's not necessary because it's just
so cool and so I will always sort of
curate the content in ways that either
deliver something that's so cool I don't
have to try to fit it into your pop
culture scaffold and other parts of
science that I think are important and I
will find a way to fit it into what you
care about and that leaves dangling some
parts of astrophysics that you might not
ever hear come out of my mouth I don't
I'm not worried about that because if
you get interested enough in the field
you'll dig up that information on your
own and you would have crossed the
thresholds of curiosity will you become
a self learner then we're done I go on
to the next person and you rise up and
if you don't otherwise become a
scientist you'll walk forth you'll go
forth with science literacy that could
manifest in other ways whether you're an
attorney and artist a poet a novelist
plenty of ways for science literacy to
manifest in this world whether or not
you're a scientist
[Music]
you